she likes it straight up and he likes it
on the rocks please welcome more
wonderful choreographer this evening
miss Paula Abdul and the very funny
Dudley Moore
well tonight we've said it with music
and dance which has been choreographed
by my tiny but perfectly proportioned
co-presenter Paula Abdul why I'm here is
obvious we're the same size into play a
wicked piano oh yes I did
um also I am also why don't why am I
saying also I don't know I guess I guess
I can remember when most film songs were
lyrical and romantic and then came the
rocky era with music to mix cement by
and now four of tonight's nominated
songs have had the courage to be lyrical
again and the fifth is a love song to a
hearing Hollywood has come full circle
this year the nominees are chances are
after all music by Tom Snow lyric by
Dean Pittsburg from earlier from Shirley
Valentine the girl who used to be me
music by Marvin Hamlisch lyric by Alan
and Marilyn Bergman from Parenthood I
love to see you smile musically
from The Little Mermaid Kista go
music by Alan Menken lyric by Howard
Ashman and from the Little Mermaid under
the sea music by Alan Menken lyrics by
Howard Ashman and the Oscar goes to Alan
Menken Howard Ashman for under the sea
from the Little Mermaid
well I won't do fish jokes just say a
couple thank yous at Disney to Jeff
Katzenberg Peter Schneider to Sam Wright
who's sang the song all the words mostly
though the John Musker and Ron Clements
whose movie Little Mermaid really is at
William Morris there's Don Ashland Mike
Brett's Ian and my beloved
Esther Sherman and at home there's my
mom there's my sister there's Nancy and
Bill I feel really lucky thank you
thanks - thanks to the musical team that
worked on the songs Robbie Merkin Thomas
pays a cherry and Jack Redford in
particular thank you and thank you to
the Academy
ladies and gentlemen half of the double
dynamite his Lethal Weapon 1 & 2 mr.
Danny Glover
good evening our next nominated film is
the true story the young man who
sacrificed his all-american boyhood
along with the very legs he walked on to
the purgatory that was Vietnam when he
got home he found that the real hell lay
before him he had survived only to find
out that no one really cared but he
cared and he did something about it
after all he was a man who was proud of
his country and the fact that he was
born on the 4th of July